the logic of predicates is a basic
concept in mathematical language as well
as being a topic on its own in
particular I'm going to talk now about
the idea that two so-called quantifiers
for all that's the upside down a and
exists that's the backward e so what's a
predicate basically a predicate is a
proposition except it's got variables in
it here's an example P of X Y is the
predicate that depends on x and y and
let's say it's defined to be X plus 2
equals Y now in order to figure out
whether or not a predicate is true I
need to know the values of the variables
in this case x and y so if I tell you
that X is 1 and that Y is 3 guess what P
of 1 in 3 P of x + y when x is 1 and Y
is 3 is true because in fact 1 plus 2 is
equal to 3 if I tell you if it X is 1
and Y is 4 then since 1 plus 2 is not
equal to 4 P of 1 + 4 is false on the
other hand since P of 1/4 is false that
makes not P of 1 + 4 true that's the
easy part
now the quantifiers are read as for all
and exists but they control a variable
so I write for all X it means 4 and it's
sorry I write upside down a X and I read
it as for all X I'm so used to reading
it that I forgot that I needed to read
symbols literally and backwards E Y is
read as there exists some Y so let's see
how that would work
the upside-down a for all acts like an
end and to understand what it means
let's look at this example let's let a
variable s range over the staff members
in 604 2 at this term which whom there
are about 30 counting the graders let's
define a predicate that depends on the
variable s called P of s that says that
s is pumped about 604 - there
Susy astok about being on the staff okay
if I tell you for all s P of s that's
exactly the same as saying that P of
Drew is true and P of Peter is true and
P of Kesha is true and a whole bunch
more ends the enthalpy of Michaela
there'll be twenty nine as if there are
thirty staff members
similarly the backwards either exists
acts like an or if I tell you that T is
now ranging over the 604 to staff just
as s was and I write B of T the
predicate of T that means T the staff
member t took 604 two before then if I
tell you that there exists a TB of T
what I'm telling you is that B of Drew
either drew took it before or Peter took
it before or Kesha took it before or
Michaela took it before this statement
is true because in fact several of the
staff members took 604 two from me
before and I like to think that the
previous one that everybody's pumped up
on the staff is true although I can't
guarantee that so let's do a little
practice with existential quantifiers
so let's agree that the variables x and
y will range for this example over the
non-negative integers and let's consider
the following predicate about why it
says that there's some X that's less
than Y Q of Y is there exists an X that
X is less than Y let's see what happens
well what about Q of three the Q of
three is saying that there is an X such
that X is less than three
well an example of such an X is 1 so
that means there is an X that's less
than three because one is and so that
makes this Q true all right what about Q
of 1 well again there's an X that's a
non-negative integer namely 0 that's
less than 1 and therefore Q of 1 is true
on the other hand Q of 0 is false
because there is no
non-negative integer that's less than
zero and so there's no value that you
can assign to X that's a non-negative
integer that will make it less than zero
okay that one's not so bad I hope
let's look at the same example with a
universal quantifier this time we'll say
that R of Y means that for every X X is
less than Y well R of one is false and
the reason is that five is a counter
example five is not less than one and so
it's not true that every X is less than
one hour of eight is false because 12 is
not less than eight and therefore not
every X is less than eight R of a googol
10 to the 100th is false because if you
let X be a googol it's not less than a
googol and so it's an example of the
fact that this doesn't hold for all X's
that part's obvious okay the thing that
tends to confuse people in the beginning
is what happens when you start mixing up
quantifiers so let's look at an
intuitive example first it might help
you remember what happens when you have
an a followed by an e and then we'll
look at an e followed by an a so suppose
I look at this statement this time I'm
gonna tell you that V ranges over the
possible computer viruses not biological
viruses the range is over Spa antivirus
software defenses against viruses and I
want to look at the predicate that says
for every virus there is a defense such
that D protects against V this defense
is good against that virus all right
so each virus I have a defense for so an
example would be these are by the way
dated viruses but that's when the slides
were made so against the mydoom virus
you could use a defender a microsoft
defender against the i-love-you virus
you could use Norton against Bob less
virus you could use zone alarm well is
that what we want
it's expensive it means that for every
different virus I need a different
defense I have to spend a fortune on
software this is not what we want so
that's when for every virus there's a
defense but the quantifiers are in the
wrong order let's reverse them suppose I
tell you that there's one defense that's
good for all viruses there is a defense
such that for every virus the protects
against V for example if thee is MIT
virus scan then it would only be would
be wonderful it was true that D protects
against all viruses there's one defense
good against every attack that's what we
want
because it's a lot cheaper all right
let's start looking at a a concrete
mathematical example that and I hope
that that preload with the viruses will
help you decipher how the quantifiers
behave so let's look at this prayer this
predicate now sorry this is a
proposition it really doesn't depend on
the values of x and y it's asking about
all possible X's in all possible Y's
whether there is one in order to figure
out whether a proposition like G is true
actually I do need to know what x and y
are ranging over cuz as you'll see
whether or not G comes out to be true
will depend on that so I'm gonna look at
the domain of deep discourse that x and
y range over and we'll suppose that the
domain is the non-negative integers so
now what G is saying is that if you give
me a non-negative integer X there is a y
that's greater than X I in other words I
can find another non-negative integer
that's bigger than X well that's
certainly true there's a simple recipe
for finding Y give me X let's choose Y
to be X plus 1 or X plus 2 but I don't
necessarily need a recipe
somewhere out there there's a why that's
bigger than X this is true so G is true
when the domain of discourse is the
non-negative integers on the other hand
when I change the domain of discourse
different things can happen so let's
look at the negative integers the
integer is less than zero and asked is
it true that for every X there's a y
that's greater than X well for a lot of
them there is if X is minus 3 then minus
2 is bigger than X if X is minus 2 then
minus 1 is bigger than X but then I'm in
trouble
if X is minus 1 there's no negative
integer that's bigger than X and so G is
false
when the domain of this course is the
negative integers well let's shift again
the point being here both were looking
at alternating quantifiers and we're
understanding that the meaning of a or
the truth of a proposition with
quantifiers depends crucially on the
domain of discourse if we let the domain
of this course be the negative reals
then what this is saying is that for
every negative real there's a bigger
negative real and that of course is true
because if you give me a negative real
are then are over 2 because it's
negative is actually bigger than are and
it will not be positive if our isn't
positive so sure enough G in this case
is true all right let's reverse the
quantifiers and see what happens it's
worth thinking about so let's call H the
assertion that for every Y sorry that
there exists a Y such that for every X X
is less than Y so intuitively what this
is saying is there's a biggest element Y
is bigger than everything well if the
domain is the non-negative integers then
H is false because there's no biggest
non-negative integer
if it's the negative integers it's false
because there's no biggest negative
integer if it's the negative reals it's
false because there's no biggest
negative real but the truth is that this
thing is going to be false in any domain
of discourse in which less than is
behaving as it should because of any y
is not gonna be bigger than itself
so you can't possibly find a biggest Y
it would have to be bigger than itself
this is going to be false in all of
these sensible domains where less than
behaves as we would expect so let's make
this slightly more interesting and make
the Y a less than area that it would
make that less than a less than or equal
to so now it's actually possible that
there could be a a biggest element that
is greater than or equal to everything
including itself and if you look at
these domains well there isn't any
greatest non-negative integer because
for any X X plus 1 is bigger there isn't
any biggest negative real same reasoning
for any R R over 2 is gonna be bigger
but for the negative integers there is a
biggest why namely minus 1 its greater
than or equal to every other negative
integer